[Music]
they're big they're scary and they can
carry cars cows and even a couple of
houses they can range from a simple dust
storm to a force that can wipe out an
entire town
unfortunately the latter is coming for
you this is a tornado normally you take
cover and hide or try to run from it but
instead we're skydiving into it whoo-hoo
what would you see inside a tornado
could you possibly survive this and what
would happen when the tornado stops this
is what if and here's what would happen
if you skydived into a tornado
unlike most natural disasters being
caught in the middle of a tornado is
actually survivable there have been
multiple reports from people who were
caught inside the eye of a tornado and
have walked away without any injuries
tornadoes are most likely to occur in
tornado alley
a stretch of land in the Midwestern
United States they form when cool dry
air from Canada and hot moist air from
Mexico clashed together to create a
vicious storm which eventually becomes a
tornado the wind in a tornado can be up
to nearly 500 km/h and its diameter can
be as wide as five kilometers so let's
jump into this thing all right now
you're inside of a tornado if you manage
to keep yourself from vomiting as you're
hurled and spun around within these
violent winds you'll quickly notice a
couple of things that happen when you're
inside a tornado the first thing you'll
probably notice would be the temperature
change inside a tornado it's 15 to 20
degrees
older than it would be outside that's
due to wind constantly being funneled
into the center of the vortex the
funneling will not only make it much
colder but it will also make the air
much thinner than what you're used to
researchers estimate that the density of
the air would be 20% lower than what's
found at high altitudes to put this in
perspective breathing in a tornado would
be the equivalent of breathing at an
altitude of 8,000 meters at that level
you generally need assistance to be able
to breathe so let's hope you don't stay
in here too long if you do you'll
quickly pass out let's give you a
special mask so you don't have to worry
about breathing another thing you'll
notice is just how smooth the air flow
inside a tornado is storm Watchers that
have briefly been inside a tornado
observed that despite it looking like a
crazy mess of wind and clouds from the
outside the air in the eye of the
tornado is actually quite smooth don't
expect a nice peaceful ride when you're
inside this thing sure maybe it would
feel like nothing else existed on earth
but unfortunately that's not the case
and it wouldn't just be a party of one
in this tornado there would be tons of
other debris with it glass wood bricks
even entire objects like houses and cars
and let's not forget about those cows
with the tornado continually picking up
other debris it would be pretty easy for
you to get hit by something and remember
these objects would be spinning at
nearly 500 km/h so unless you get out of
this thing quickly or happen to be
incredibly lucky you'll most likely get
hit by debris and then become severely
injured or die but if you manage to
survive all that the tornado will
eventually dissipate this is because of
the cool air entering the vortex
now the tornado is gone and you can pop
your parachute and you're free keep in
mind though it's basically impossible
for this to happen and for you to
survive you'll have a much higher chance
of surviving if you manage to avoid the
tornado
seek some sort of shelter but what if we
could nuke tornadoes and stop them
altogether that sounds like a story for
another what if